what president in the last you know
however many years who has done a job
where you're like okay this guy came
through and did his part like who has
been someone where you've said that's my
guy I'm sticking with him he did great
he came through he kept his word da d d
who was the person that well I'm I mean
I'm with Reagan on the point sorry I'm
not one of these nut Republicans who can
only site Reagan drives me crazy but I
think he was the one who said with
politicians if they're 80% with me and
20% against me that's enough that's
enough that's fine for me and so I'd say
that's true with um a a lot of them I
think you have to be kind
of I think it's hard to be a normal
person and run for president you have to
be a little bit of a of a narcissist or
something I'd say more than 80%
satisfied with Governor DeSantis you're
80% satisfied more than okay with what
there's very little I would criticize
about DeSantis